et je voudrais qu'on revienne un instant
sur les propos de Muriel Robin vous
savez qu'elle a elle a répondu sans son
filtre à une interview Muriel Robin qui
est revenue les journées qu'on revienne
sur ça sur cette cette déclaration il
est pas normal de boire une bouteille de
champagne presque tous les soirs on a
parlé de l'alcoolisme et on va dire ce
qu'on appelle l'alcoolisme monde en
écoute
[Musique]
sur les planches et sur le petit écran
Muriel Robin enchaîne depuis quelques
jours les interviews promos mais aussi
les déclarations chocs après avoir
affirmé que les homosexuels souffraient
de discrimination dans le cinéma la
comédienne est revenue sans langue de
bois sur son alcoolisme passé mon père
avait eu la mauvaise idée de me faire
boire une bouteille à 12 ans c'était
rentré dans mon disque dur dans cette
interview accordée à TV Grandes chaînes
elle confie avoir plus s'en sortir grâce
à sa femme et affirme avoir été une
alcoolique mondaine il était anormal de
boire une bouteille de champagne presque
tous les soirs
une bouteille de champagne presque tous
les soirs alors elle se livre quand même
son filtre c'est c'est alors je pense
qu'il faut il faut passer au-delà moi ce
qui m'a choqué tout de suite c'est la
bouteille de champagne parce que la
bouteille de champagne c'est pour les
riches et une situation privilégiée
[Musique]
du champagne
excusez-moi le champagne
le champagne voilà c'est un milieu
j'ai réussi à passer outre et c'est très
bien qu'elle décrivent ses addictions
parce que des gens a dit qui ont des
addictions vont peut-être pouvoir guérir
en l'écoutant voilà mais au début je
trouve que le Champagne se plainte de
boire une tête de champagne de te
raconter la l'honnêteté de te raconter
étant donné qu'elle te raconte sa vie et
la réalité donc même si c'est une
bouteille à 500 euros par soir mais en
fait elle te raconte ce qu'elle a vécu
donc on te demande pas de juger si c'est
bien ou pas on te demande
mais on te demande pas ton avis sur le
fait qu'elle dépensait de l'argent dans
une bouteille de champagne alors le roi
de le raconter
le monde hein il y a beaucoup de
personnes voilà
quand on parle d'alcoolisme on a
forcément l'image de quelqu'un qui a pas
forcément beaucoup d'argent qui boit de
la piquette or c'est pas vrai on sait
bien que c'est pas vrai l'alcoolisme
touche toutes les couches de la société
et je trouve très fort qu'elle en parle
et qu'elle en parle avec honnêteté même
avec une bouteille de champagne
ça veut dire qu'on s'en rendait pas
compte qu'on devient alcoolique ça quand
on dit quand c'est mondain en fait elle
est très courageuse de c'est formidable
ça prouve qu'elle arrive au bout de sa
psychothérapie d'ailleurs parce que
maintenant Ouest se révèle où elle est
forte elle dit des choses très fortes et
c'est une excellente actrice et elle
dénonce plein de choses moi j'ai dit
bravo mais ça prouve vraiment qu'elle va
mieux et qu'elle arrive au bout les
températures elle a jamais cachée depuis
des années depuis presque ses débuts
même avant ses débuts mais c'est bien
effectivement qu'elle parle c'est bien
effectivement des personnalités prennent
la parole et parlent aujourd'hui de leur
maladie quelles qu'elles soient
d'ailleurs la maladie ça se fait de plus
en plus est-ce que je sais pas
seuls ils s'identifient aussi à toutes
ces stars qui seraient parfaite mais
elles ne le sont pas donc moi je trouve
ça oui je trouve ça très bien si ça peut
aider des gens non parce qu'en fait
c'est un alcoolisme en fait sournois et
un peu insidieux c'est à dire qu'on va
une représentation on vous offre un
verre puis après il y a un dîner après
une représentation au théâtre puis là ah
bah tu reprends un verre donc on reprend
un verre et petit à petit c'est un
cercle vicieux en fait on passe pas une
nuit enfin une soirée sans boire du
champagne peu importe du mousseux peu
importe de la bière bref et donc on est
totalement dépendant moi je trouve que
c'est ouais c'est bien
c'est bien qu'elle en parle parce que du
coup j'aime bien que les femmes aussi
disent qu'elles y a beaucoup de femmes
qui ont un alcoolisme monde beaucoup
c'est très et puis on reconnaît
c'est-à-dire que voilà elle se dit à un
moment on prend conscience est-ce que ça
vous est arrivé peut-être à l'un d'entre
vous de de boire mais sans se dire je
suis alcoolique je prends un petit verre
de temps en temps vers le soir et à un
moment de se dire voilà stop il va
falloir que je réduise la voilure ça
vous est déjà arrivé ça se je sais pas
moi j'ai arrêté de boire le 1er janvier
dernier je me suis dit j'ai fait un
bracelet Harry c'est pour ça voilà ouais
mais j'ai continué j'ai pas repris en
fait j'ai pas retouché parce que
l'alcool c'était pour le challenge non
parce que alors au départ je c'était un
peu pour le challenge etc et en fait je
me suis rendu compte que quand je buvais
en fait que quand je sortais ou quand je
commençais à boire j'avais pas de limite
quoi donc c'est à dire que je commençais
à part une bière un truc machin un verre
de vin et puis hop c'était voilà c'est
la fête et des shots et des trucs et
tout va bien
parce que chaque ça fait un peu riche
hein
et en fait
c'est la gueule de bois etc donc ouais
c'était compliqué donc en fait j'ai
décentré l'alcool le truc c'est que la
conclusion tu as besoin de tout stopper
parce que tu peux pas boire normalement
c'est un petit peu
connaissance je suis nul en modération
je sais que je suis pas bonne en
modération
tu vois et ben je me suis dit
écoute on nous étions avec Kelly mais
voilà et donc du coup j'ai commencé j'ai
commencé à boire et en fait j'aime bien
le dossier je sais pas ce que c'était
dîner mais ça a l'air d'être très drôle
donc du coup j'ai décentré ça mais au
moins c'est honnête c'est honnête il
faut savoir que les médecins ont
l'habitude de dire que si tu n'es pas
capable de ne pas boire de soir de suite
c'est que tu es alcoolique
de ne pas boire si tu n'es pas
voilà
[Rires]
il faut faire attention effectivement
avec parce que en France effectivement
l'alcool le vin ça fait partie de
du terroir et moi quand je bois plus
comme je bois plus on me dit oh tu es
relou tu peux pas voilà ça fait partie
du truc qu'il faut trinquer il faut
célébrer mais moi je m'amuse de la même
manière que moi je me suis retrouvé dans
une soirée quand j'étais plus jeune et
les gars ont dit elle sert à rien elle
le voit pas d'accord j'ai entendu ça par
rapport
il faut le le rapatrier vers les jeunes
tous les jeunes qui sortent entre eux au
bout d'un moment et on peut être tenté
de boire et puis celui qui ne boit pas
quelqu'un qui ne boit pas il y aura le
terrain gare ou ça va il faut dire aux
jeunes non buvez pas même si vos copains
vous disent t'es ringard tu es nul bah
c'est pas grave je veux pas boire et
surtout ne pas conduire et pas conduire
évidemment pour les jeunes surtout
surtout le rappeler le Martelet voilà
exactement Guillaume non mais il faut
plus nous sensibiliser je pense que
quand on a grandi on nous a pas dit que
boire c'était vraiment dangereux
d'accord mais l'alcool il faut dire
quand même que ça détruit des vies que
c'est à l'origine de d'agression de viol
d'accidents de la route c'est une des
premières causes de mortalité voilà
c'est ce qui tue le plus et je ne
comprends pas pourquoi on interdit pas
plus l'alcool dans certains endroits
voir totalement parce que pour moi c'est
un des fléaux de notre société et je
pense qu'il faudrait l'interdire et
c'est pas pour rien qu'il est interdit
dans certaines religion bah moi je pense
à 100% bah oui
[Musique]
c'est extrêmement dangereux mais c'est
interdit l'alcool ça n'est pas interdit
et c'est beaucoup plus vite
c'est extrêmement dangereux pour la
santé
toi-même tu me causes pas d'accident tu
ne donnes pas lieu à des bastons à des
ingrédients
c'est une catastrophe
avec modération
c'est formidable
je trouve Guillaume il y a
qui sont beaucoup de mal à la santé
parce qu'il mange trop on va pas
interdire la nourrir
ça fait du mal à ceux qui en boivent et
aux autres oui il y a une question
d'éducation aussi par exemple chez moi
mon bébé pas de vin du tout et je me
suis rattrapé
on va faire non
c'est vrai qu'il y a une question
d'éducation moi je je j'ai appris à mes
enfants à apprécier des bons vins et pas
boire n'importe quoi je vous leur avez
[Rires]
je suis je suis né dans une région qui
qui est une région viticole et toi aussi
et non mais sincèrement c'est important
d'apprendre et à apprécier les mains et
à ne pas boire n'importe comment voilà
alors moi je suis pas très bon client
parce que je ne vois absolument pas je
n'ai pas la culture de l'alcool et même
lorsque j'étais pro en basket les 3e
mi-temps et tout ça c'est les choses qui
m'intéressaient pas trop donc voilà
plutôt serein et bien sevré on va se
retrouver dans quelques minutes Cyril
Hanouna sera là